il est tout nouveau et pèse déjà lourd à
lui seul ce transformateur d'une
puissance de 40 mégawatts
vos trois cent cinquante mille euros et
sa masse est estimée à 40 tonnes un
convoi exceptionnel moyens spéciaux et
nous car il faut éviter choqué agression
sur les 10 km de routes à réaliser entre
fort-de-france ichel cher à ce prix là
vous me voyez le bébé et surtout la
chose importante faire toute la
maintenance nécessaires prédictive sur
ce genre d'appareil parce que vous
pensez bien qu'on n'en a pas 10 comme ça
en stock
et si jamais demain on devait avoir un
impromptu de sur un incident on
risquerait d'avoir des problèmes
d'alimentation sur l'ensemble de la zone
dernière opération avant son
installation
les manoeuvres vont être prises
plusieurs fois on ne prend aucun risque
sécurité maximale autour de la machine
elle va être intégré à ce nouveau poste
électrique bien plus moderne et couverts
il remplacera le poste actuel construit
en 1975 on s'adapte aux nouvelles
technologies donc concernant les postes
sources en fait on est passés
historiquement par différentes
technologies dans les années 80 c'était
une technologie analogique et puis au
début des années 2000 où on a commencé à
passer progressivement à la technologie
numérique et donc ça permet d'avoir des
ouvrages et des protections douvres âge
qui réagissent en fait plus finement par
rapport aux aléas qui peuvent se
produire sur le réseau depuis ce poste
source électricité va être distribuée
sur trois communes de fort-de-france cas
ce pilote est celle cher
quarante mille foyers sont concernés il
devrait bénéficier d'un service en
alimentation électrique performant
c'est un jour important puisque ça va
vraiment améliorer
la qualité de cette distribution ancien
poste source qui était située juste un
peu plus loin quand il y avait une panne
c'était difficile de trouver les pièces
de rechange coût des travaux
15 millions d'euros la mise en service
de ce nouveau poste est annoncée pour
avril 2019
le programme de modernisation des postes
sources poursuit demain avec
l'installation de deuxième
transformateur h el cheikh au total
cette année trois transformateurs de
puissance seront installés